journalists are starting to they're
starting to wake up and they're starting
to get really annoyed with Kareem
Jean-Pierre who will not answer a
question properly she it's she she may
as well just say like she's tragically
un talented here's some real here's what
she should do at this point right let's
play again so so ask me a basic question
and I'll answer it
uh so what is happening with the
response to Hurricane white situation so
it's a great situation kuwaits wait uh
well that's a great question the other
day I was out in New York with a friend
of mine and we went to this really great
place called Lafayette in New York it's
on Lafayette and they have beef tartar
it's amazing it's actually some of the
best so uh next question
so basically what you're saying her
response should be [ __ ] you next
question
oh sorry I'm that's what my bad
okay
to answer the question just tell us
something interesting you know like she
could be like
oh yes that's an excellent question did
you guys see the latest House of dragons
it was you know I don't understand what
was going on because like I turned it on
it's the future now you know did you
watch this yeah they changed the actors
but it's the future now yeah and like
renares has a bunch of kids I just got
confused to what I was watching and
turned it off that's a better answer
than anything she could have said I'd be
like oh that's a lesson solving is that
is that what happened on Australia top
of mind off top of mind I would I would
rather someone be like Karine the
president called out to a deceased
member of Congress can you explain
what's going on I'd be like yeah
actually I've been watching Better Call
Saul and I don't know if you guys saw
the episode the last one where the the
German guy gets executed man what a
great show what a great show you know it
was really it was really crazy to see
Mike kind of like becoming this
character where he doesn't want to kill
the person but you know eventually
becomes his cold-blooded killer and
Breaking Bad next question I kind of
disagree with you Andrew I think she's
doing a great job because as a White
House spokesperson she's supposed to
represent the administration and what
better way to do that than to be
confused when she's answering
she's doing it in a very good way and
she she does represent the
administration perfectly what if you're
mentioning how like the journalists are
just like getting fed up with being lied
to What If eventually she just snaps
because like she's desperately trying to
spin the unspinable and so he just comes
out and she goes I'll be honest with you
I think that dude's brother this brain
is just gone I don't even know what to
say anymore look I've been trying really
really hard to spin these answers for
you guys but clearly we're at a point
where everybody knows Joe Biden can't
think straight yeah the guy has two
brain aneurysms in 1988 he's not doing
too well what do you think he's going to
be doing
that'd be amazing I would love that what
do you think his brain doesn't work next
question but I don't know I don't know
if if these journalists are being lied
to I just think that she's she's just
not answering a question or or when the
other day you one of the dumbest things
I've ever heard in my life from anybody
in any Administration Peter juicy Aster
is they they were talking about the
Border
um and they were she was like well you
know they just don't they don't walk
just like walk over the Border they
don't walk across the border and he's
like no that's exactly what happens
that's exactly like what world do you
live in I've been there I can confirm
that that's that's exactly dude it's
amazing because she says nothing like
the answers she gives aren't like when
when asked about the deceased member of
Congress she goes well
um and she looks down and she goes um
well uh Joe Biden um was honoring these
people and she was of top of mind
that's what she said she was awesome Jay
Carney for Obama did the same thing oh
yeah even slower look what I loved about
uh Kaylee mcinerney was that she had the
book and she'd be like you're lying
journalist but now it's like what's
happening is journalists are actually
asking it's like Peter Ducey I don't
know if he like was a wake-up call to
these people but now they're asking real
questions that that you can't spin it
anymore it's just unspinnable I mean the
binder you're you're right Richie the
binder has always been there but it's
just so blatant that she she doesn't
have a thought on her own a thought of
her own she just has to go to the binder
99 of the time I just I imagine that
like when they were deciding who's going
to replace gen saki you know they had
they had the candidates and they were
like this is Kareem she can she can
string words together for a long time
yeah they don't mean anything but she's
she's really good at those word salads
they shouldn't it's all a word salad
it's all it's crazy they shouldn't she
should not she's there we know why she's
there John Kirby should be there John
Kirby
is a he's articulate he actually knows
what he's talking about
he should be there but they went which
Kareen Jean-Pierre so she could be like
the first this and the first that and
check off a bunch of boxes I wonder if
you know behind the scenes the White
House they're watching The Press
briefings and they're just laughing at
the journalists they're like they still
show up like at what point do you just
stop showing up she's not gonna answer
question she's not even like that's why
I was making the joke about if she just
started talking about breaking bad or
something at least you'd have some
coherent thought like she would be
telling you a thing you'd be like okay
well it's unrelated but at least it's
something no she's it's what is of top
of mind
she was clearly off top of Mind are you
saying that like he was thinking about
her or something and that's why he
misspoke what does that mean what is
that phrase but she just kept repeating
it and then my favorite is when they're
like okay I'm gonna ask you again
because you'd answer the question I I I
already explained it to you I she was
off topic and then she read it again
from the Bible and then and then there
was a a journalist who said well look
you know I think about John Lennon every
day he's on he's on top of mind and I
don't expect him to show up wait a
journalist said that yeah journalists
said that like I'm paraphrasing but but
he said and she's like well when John
Lennon becomes the president then you
know we can talk about it then
comes the president yeah like she's just
an idiot that's like a gen sacky like
you condescend the question yeah without
answering yeah she was so smug but at
least at least she could spin at least
she was competent enough to be smugged
she was the state department spokesman
under Obama I didn't think she was that
I I wasn't really a good man either but
no but I think she was for for the spin
that she spun she spuns spin you know
what I mean like Kareem jump here it's
just garbled word salad it'd be like
here let's try it again ask me a
question
you mentioned Jake Harney before uh
there there was a a hullabaloo with Joe
Biden uh when there was like the I think
it was like the bird flu and he was like
wow you know I wouldn't want to get on a
plane because if somebody cops and like
the whole plane's gonna get get bird flu
and uh and then the Press actually it
was actually Jake Tapper I believe who
was like pushing Jay Carney it's like
um you know that's not true right like
you know the and then they're like well
what the vice president meant to say and
they're like because I don't know what
he meant to say is not what he said you
know like they were trying to spin a
thing that that Joe Biden actually
believed he got a thing wrong and they
were like no what he meant to say it's
like no no it's what he said he was
wrong and you can't admit it asked him a
question
uh so what did Joe Biden what was Joe
Biden referring to when he was trying to
uh
call out an audience member who's who
died a month ago Volkswagen oatmeal
Ferrari
cumulonimbus Rhododendron that's correct
yeah
um methyl prednisolone oh my yes
um that was a big one Miss Smith
how do you say that
salaciousness no no bismuth salicylic
cell I don't know you get what I mean
though um Pepto-Bismol
yeah chori queso guacamole languages
yeah and uh graphene
like she may as well just be saying
random words and the journalists keep
asking expect it's like they're sticking
their hand in a fire thinking something
different is going to happen every time
it's like the way you say it not how you
say it it's like if someone says I went
down to Peru and you're like they're
smart I don't know how to pronounce Peru
you know what's crazy though they really
tried to do a hijab on all the
Republican press secretaries like there
was a scene it was um uh reliable
sources uh they they put out a story
where they said uh Sarah Huckabee
Sanders says you don't get a lot of
answers from not a lot of answers and
and it's her saying it was like a
montage of her saying I don't know which
didn't mean that she didn't know the
answer to the question she was saying
things like I don't know why Democrats
would want this thing and they put and
they and they made because of course
they're dishonest and they put together
this Montage but with with you know Jen
sacky you could do that or Jake Harney
you could do the same you could do the
same thing but actually he didn't have a
lot of answers and neither did jensaki
and oh like I need to remember this uh
I'll Circle back to you you know how
many Circle backs there were at the
beginning but that's that's why I mean
the whole Daily Briefing is an act in
the first place like the present uh
President Clinton started the daily the
White House briefings and it was
basically like the 24-hour news Cycles
came out they needed stuff coming out of
the white house consistently content and
it became like I started working at NBC
in 2000 and uh end of 2012 and I decided
to leave the cable news game because I
was like this is such BS because it's
you pay you play pay your dues you ask
the right questions and if you ask the
right questions you play the game for
long enough then you'll you'll be one of
those front men right so you just have
to play the game
in cohorts with the White House and so
it's like this relationship between the
fourth estate and the government that is
the exact opposite of the purpose of the
press which is like to you know ask the
tough question I think they should just
get rid of it it's TV time
that's all it is because they have a
press office yeah they should do a tick
tock briefing there is such thing as
email they can just go and say Here's my
question please answer it in an email
but instead they're you know I mean if I
don't watch this stuff I've never
watched I watched it every single day
it's you may as well just sit in front
sit in your bathroom and flush the
toilet every few seconds that's what
you're watching that's what I watch yeah
but it depends on like what's Kimberly
mcaninny she actually answered questions
but hold on but she was calling out the
corporate press that was awesome I mean
she she didn't have to do that but she
did and she did it very well she was
amazing and and uh Sanders was great too
she they they were they were very very
amazing press secretaries Sean Spicer on
the other hand total garbage he he said
he set the tone he pitched him on a
motorized Podium after uh Jenny McCarthy
what's her name remember um live did
that spoof and he they had who wasn't
Melissa McCarthy she was on a motorized
Podium it was super slow and I was like
a sash on Spicer I was like hey man I
want to give you a motorized Podium
that's so fast I have a skateboard that
goes 25. we'll put flames on it and
we'll rip that Podium around DC and
it'll go viral how awesome you didn't
like my idea at all how awesome would it
be if uh Dave Smith actually wins the
presidency and then Michael Mouse
becomes the press secretary
that it'd just be it'd be so amazing
he'd just be like destroy them for one
he'd be ragging on the corporate press
would be hilarious but then he'd
probably just say things exactly as they
are I think it would just be an empty
room after like two weeks just no one
would go anymore why because they just
be getting wrecked and they're like no
no I think now let's just ruined myself
someone would ask like what's going on
with the withdrawal of troops from Syria
and the Middle East and it'd be like
there's no reason for us to be at war in
the Middle East
like huge like Dave Smith would be like
running the wars we're getting everybody
out of here this is a waste of our time
and money and then you there's been
there'd be no spin they'd be like yeah
we're ending the Foreign Wars like we
promised yeah but then Lockheed Martin
would call up NBC and be like yo you
guys can't send a reporter there anymore
can you imagine it would be an empty
room but let's think about that with all
those clips where it's like brought to
you by Pfizer what do you think the
media would do with like a president
Dave Smith you got president Dave Smith
vice president majeure with a with a
Michael Mouse press secretary they would
the news would be the the most insane
thing ever there would be like like
photoshopped images of Michael Mouse
kicking puppies like Lockheed would be
like shut him down like I don't care
like it would just be just be the
craziest news you'd ever you could
imagine if you thought it was bad with
Trump imagine actually getting some
Libertarians and who are like yeah we're
gonna shut down the military industrial
complex yeah they wouldn't get that
that's the point it's like they wouldn't
let it happen well and for that matter
think about the news cycle if they
actually became competitive
right now among Millennials
overwhelmingly they reject both parties
most like younger people are more okay
with Republicans I'll put this way
younger people that lean conservative or
libertarian are more okay with the
Republican party than young people are
with the Democratic party young
left-distellini individuals despise
Democrats it's like 35 of them of
Millennials in gen Z think the
Democratic party is trash but they are
leftists they are left-leaning or
liberal so it's possible that you'll get
eventually a third party that actually
breaks through I don't know about
winning the presidency but I just
imagine if there's a real risk one of
the one of the fears among Democrats is
the libertarian party actually pulls
votes from the Democratic party not the
Republican they thought that um
they thought the libertarian party was
going to hurt the Republican party but I
think what happened in 2016 is it
actually hurt Democrats it pulls their
votes so they would have no choice but
to try and destroy the libertarian
candidates because it's bad for them for
the establishment I think that'd be
that'd be that'd be interesting to see
what are they going to do about it huh
it could be a Pfizer party a Pfizer
party yeah they'd probably win the
Pfizer I mean yeah if if uh if
corporations are people my friend yeah
exactly then why couldn't a corporation
run for office well now we have the fun
people speaking on behalf of
Corporations but pretending they're
still people
yeah but that's what our White House
Press Secretary is doing right now I
don't know if there if there's a
solution to all the political BS that's
going on I feel like
it's just gotten to the point where the
emperor has no clothes even the
journalists now can't pretend otherwise
and there's no there's no solution
there's no like moment where people all
agree like hey this this probably isn't
working let's get like some competent
people here no it's just like I won't
let you win so I'll do whatever it takes
even if it means putting Biden in office
I don't know I think that there is
some kind of change that will happen
from this like if you looked at the last
major populist election or major
populist I guess uprising
You could argue that there are a couple
more in between but William Jennings
Bryan in 1896 gave that famous speech
the cross of gold
and he wanted to switch the silver
standard which would help small
businesses and farmers and William
Jennings Brian's was like 36 years old
went into the DNC gave this amazing
speech total Dark Horse candidate uh
took the presidential candidacy ended up
losing
but both political parties changed
majorly in the wake of that and actually
the Bull Moose Party Teddy Roosevelt
that was kind of the aftermath of both
parties that's when the Democratic party
really switched from the party of the
South to the starting towards the
working class part of the working class
which you know FDR's party I mean not
really racist around then for a couple
decades yeah look I'm not here to defend
the Democratic party of 1896 I'm just
saying that the 1890s the [ __ ] the shift
the shift started when the star course
came out of nowhere and gave this
amazing speech about how he's going to
help out the little guy and even though
he didn't win he came close and it
forced both parties to reckon with the
fact that they weren't acknowledging
that aspect of the population so I don't
know I want a good thing I want to talk
about this story here we'll talk about
Jordan Peterson oh by the way rule of
thumb
yeah real quick it was William
Blackstone 1723
uh it was
that was the basis of U.S common law
which came from English common law which
was the rule of thumb but he didn't
explicitly State the thumb law in the
United States thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there